before purchasing a single seed think
about how you plan to market your
products there's not a one-size-fits-all
approach to developing a marketing plan
but it takes time to research develop
relationships and understand what will
help you sell your products marketing
can depend on several factors product
quality quantity uniqueness timing
location and relationships for example a
restaurant would typically want fresh
high quality and consistent quantities
of produce providing these may require
more management and coordination but you
would typically receive a premium price
and marketing to these businesses base
your plan on your capabilities while the
plan will develop and evolve it's
important to write it out so that you
can review it your plan will likely
include selling several different
products at several different markets
being organized gives you more time
flexibility and freedom to handle tasks
as they arise keeping important
financial documents in a secure place
allows you to easily locate them when
meeting with your accountant or banker
also having set plans for what you want
your employees to do during the week in
relief stress because you know how
business tasks are being handled write
down your plans as much as possible this
will help you think through what you
need to do implement it and later review
and see how it is working for example if
you've developed a budget and tracked
your costs you'll be able to monitor and
make changes to improve your
profitability farm management software
is available that helps a farm create
plans and to-do lists whether it's paper
trails phone apps websites or
spreadsheets anything that improves
business organization is recommended
financials include budgets crop wreckers
expenses and tax documents having a
system of how you record and organize
this information is important you might
think you can keep track of everything
in your head but the more you have
documented and written down the more you
can earn for you and make adjustments to
your business producers we've worked
with tell us it takes less time than
anticipated to keep good records and
very quickly this all the benefits of
having good financials we do not
encourage keeping good records for
regulatory purposes but good records
could be valuable if you were audited or
examined as it can clear up confusion or
can conclude an audit much quicker the
IRS does not require specific kinds of
records but states that you can choose
any system that clearly shows your
income and expenses start small and
continue to work on each area if you
would never developed a marketing plan
writing down what you are currently
doing and making tiny adjustments could
be a big step for a new producer
planting crops for the first time is a
big deal starting small keeps things
manageable and allows room to grow the
operation don't be afraid to change or
to try something new this is also true
for developing a new market don't expect
to have all of your crop in a new market
the first year but slowly build and
develop it over time relationships are
critically important to the success of
any business
ask yourself there are opportunities to
be involved with organizations and
individuals that can help accomplish
your goals album extension is available
as a resource as our other agencies like
your local USDA office Alabama
Department of Ag and industries and
other farm organizations
[Music]